tell me all about your character in
wasteland because it's set in Leeds with
Manchester we all know you for shameless
so how is it compared making wastelands
Oh someone said is there any
similarities I said a young
working-class lad with an alcoholic
parent I have no idea what you're
talking about it's completely different
okay it it was really good because the
character of Charlie it does come from a
really tough background single mom
alcoholic and I really approached it
kind of researching thoroughly so sports
counselors and then any anything that
entailed in the script which thought
worth looking into then all of a sudden
the project came even more interesting
when you do that if I almost an
education then with that a nice journey
and it doesn't want to be involved in it
and then goes through something then it
gets dragged into it it was a really
really good ride and turbulent and
that's what I loved about the character
and it's like his life he had such a
turbulent life you know instability and
insecurities and playing all that
together and putting it all together
with the research on top of that if the
key really kind of kin to life vomit I
really enjoy playing it yes was there
anything that really surprised when you
were doing your research yeah it was
kind of our speaking sir two women in
Leeds about kind of dealing with it
apparently is an alcoholic and out and
out the childhood function if she was on
Iran as well and and it was really
interesting to see that they do get you
know what I sport is kind of really
helpful and the same thank goodness for
grandparents as well you know but in
Challis case he doesn't have
grandparents and that's kind of when
they try and stepped it she said they
try and step in as little kind of as
possible to help but kind of but what
was interesting when you get to 18 year
old I'll just cuts out and you're left
on your own and then I found that quite
you know it moved from from this help
and the structure to being took away and
Charlie isn't educated in the sense of
kind of you know a routine a bad time
you know structure in his life and and
it was really interesting going into
that in detail because that's not
something I can you know personally
relate to so have you found it as a
young actor because I
mentioned that you've got quite a
structure and a cent in your own life
haven't you having to do script readings
rehearsals all that sort of sir I kind
of feel I have more structure and
stability in my life when when I'm not
jiving I think when your job in this
business is so much instability and you
never know where you are next you can
never plan one week to the next so I
find it quite you know compared to come
home and private life it I find it
really you know there's a real
instability to it she's quite a bit
unnerving actually speaking about
instability what you got coming up next
well I've just finished the drama called
the town for ITV so three Pat drama with
andrew scott julie mckenzie martin
clunes charlotte riley and it it's about
kind of a murder case and is it a murder
qatar these suicide and kind of goes
through but it's really different for
ITV and really kind of fresh and new and
be looking forward to see the final
product what's it like working with
those guys yeah it was great it was good
i mean i was kind of in and out and and
you know but the time you know working
with andrew it was really kind of
professional and disciplined and i liked
his style of working out as for the
others you know but I Lites East I love
working and it's really intense and it
kind of with purpose you know kind of
actor would you say you are in turn you
mentioned intensity though how would you
approach your acting I approach my team
can I think it the foundation is a
passion for it and kind of educate
himself about the carrots from the part
for research through looking into it
because if you do that it can bring
scenes to life you know what comes from
the heart goes to the heart is it's a
famous scene isn't it and I think that
strikes you with you Sarah in what you
do and you care about what you do and
you believe in what you do
you